I was very impressed you had your first
show and your first guest on your first
show which is brand new jay-z yes that
is sweet that's really sweet so he's the
guest and this has just got to be a
dream come true
yes not only is he the first guest he
says some things about Trump and then
Trump tweets about what he said on your
show you must have been just unbowed
nine but last time I was that happy I
was on pornhub it was giving out so much
advertising for a site that really
doesn't need it no it was it's like
fairytale stuff man yeah I mean I came
out to this town eight years ago I
wanted to get my own show I know I
didn't get turned down by anybody
because nobody would take the meeting
yeah okay yeah and then your first guest
is jay-z Oprah tweets about it and then
Trump tweets about it and you're like I
should have voted for this guy because
now it's like we got like a billion
Lilly a billion impressions on Twitter
because it's in crap but once Trump
starts tweeting about you then all the
same people have to put him in place and
it's wonderful yeah he said actually in
his own way the great uniter has Trump
tweeted about you before because you've
been on you know CNN for a while now and
you've been fairly outspoken you know he
never tweeted about me directly but
there was a time that he at a press
conference well behind the scenes
meeting said that you know Van Jones is
terrible or whatever and they printed
that so I took a screenshot and I
tweeted it and then I like retweeted it
and then like unreached we did it and
retweeted again because I want to make
sure that everybody saw it it was like
my biggest moment in my career you're
thrilled that the president was behind
closed doors angrily yelling about you
saying that you're no good yeah
you